it is 11 o'clock ladies and gentlemen
boys and girls this year's Nobel Prize
in Chemistry deals with g-protein
coupled receptors the picture behind me
shows you the latest development in a
long series of develops that have taken
place over the past few decades and
summarizes work that has been made by
this year's two laureates the g-protein
coupled receptors are an ingenious set
of operators in a system that works in a
modular fashion in all multicellular
organisms making it possible for our one
part of our body to understand what's
going on in another part and to send
signals to tell what to do rather much
like the captain of an old sailing ship
shouting set the sails and you've all
seen what happens in the movies well
some people enter the rigging other
starts pulling on ropes and half of them
start singing chanteys just from one
single order the same thing in our
bodies if adrenaline goes out into our
bodies it elicits different responses to
our vision to our muscles to our hearts
and so on the laureates Robert Lefkowitz
and Brian kobilka have been part of this
development from the very beginning and
they have been leading the way
our first lecturer Robert Lefkowitz was
born 1943 in New York he receive his MD
from Columbia University in New York he
is Howard used investigator and he works
as you see all his titles here the
Medical Institute James P Duke professor
of medicine professor biochemistry at
Duke University Medical Center in
Dhahran New York City sorry North
Carolina thank you
the USA
but of course above an all his a
scientist so welcome to the stage
thank you very much needless to say it
is a real pleasure and an honor to be
here with you today
the idea of receptors has fascinated
scientists for more than a hundred years
and it's obviously fascinated Brian
kobilka and myself for the entirety of
our research careers today we know that
one family of receptors that you've just
heard about the g-protein coupled
receptors also known as the seven
transmembrane receptors represent by far
the largest most versatile and the most
ubiquitous of the several families of
plasma membrane receptors they comprise
almost a thousand genes in the human
genome and they regulate virtually all
known physiological processes in humans
including our senses of taste smell and
vision they also are the commonest
target of therapeutic drugs accounting
for perhaps 50% of all prescription drug
sales in the world now despite the very
central position of research on these
receptors in current biomedical research
it's really only in the last 30 years or
so that there's been a named general
agreement that they even existed prior
to that time their very existence was a
subject of much controversy and
skepticism perhaps the earliest explicit
suggestion that there might be such a
thing as a receptor was made by the
famous British pharmacologist JN Langley
in 1905 he wrote so we may suppose that
in all cells to constituents at least to
be distinguished a chief substance which
is concerned with the chief function of
the cell as contraction and secretion
and receptive substances which are acted
upon by chemical bodies and in certain
cases by nervous stimuli the receptive
substance effects or is capable of
affecting the metabolism of the chief
substance so here we have the first
explicit suggestion of a receptor in
terms of a particular item which is able
to
both interact with a stimulus bind it
presumably and then act on the cell to
change its actions but this idea of a
receptor was not widely accepted and in
fact it was in general ignored or
derided as an example
Langly student ironically sir Sir Henry
Dale a famous pharmacologist who
actually won the Nobel Prize for his
work on cholinergic transmission had
this to say 40 years later about his
mentor's receptor idea
it is a misstatement the fact to say
that the action of adrenaline picks out
certain such effector cells and leaves
others unaffected it's a simple
deduction that the affected cells have a
special affinity of some kind for
adrenaline but I doubt whether the
attribution to such cells of adrenaline
receptors there's more than restate this
deduction in another form now even more
ironic perhaps is this next statement by
the very famous American pharmacologist
of the mid twentieth century
Raymond Dahlquist now Alquist in 1948
published a seminal paper for which he
won the Lasker prize in which he
suggested based on conventional
pharmacological studies he had done that
there must be two types of receptors for
adrenaline which he called alpha and
beta but his idea of receptor was quite
different because 30 years later as
recently as 1973 he wrote the following
this would be true if I was so
presumptuous as to believe that alpha
and beta receptors really did exist
there are those that think so and even
propose to describe their intimate
structure to me they're an abstract
concept conceived to explain observed
responses of tissues produced by
chemicals of various structure he
actually wrote this after serving on a
symposium with me in which I presented
some of my earliest work
so it was against this background of
real skepticism about the existence of
receptors that those of us who were
interested in bringing these mythical
molecules to life began the work some 40
years ago in the early 70s and it was
clear to all of us I think at the time
that if we just was to succeed in
proving their existence we would need to
develop a whole suite of new
technologies which did not then exist
and the first of these would have to be
some way of directly tagging the
receptors for study that is to say radio
ligand binding experiments and so in the
early 70s together with student rusty
Williams and postdoc macaron we set out
and was successful in developing radio
ligand binding studies for initially the
beta adrenergic receptors and then the
Alpha hydrologic receptors and when
those new techniques came the ability to
study receptor regulation by a myriad of
factors the ability to discover new
receptor subtypes and interestingly the
ability to develop some interesting
theories of receptor action as an
example we found that in competition
curves antagonists beta antagonists such
as our parental all gave steep yoona
phasic curves of a single affinity
whereas agonists like epinephrine or
isoproterenol gave shallow curves which
in fact were composed of two components
a high and a low affinity one addition
of guanine nucleotides such as GTP
converted all the high to low affinity
receptors and now gave us a steep curve
in order to explain this initially
perplexing phenomenology Andre de Leon
and I developed the so-called ternary
complex model which proposed that
agonists combined with the free receptor
to form a low affinity agonist receptor
complex and then that complex further
combines with another initially unknown
component we call that ex to form a high
affinity ternary complex ARX the
modulatory effects of guanine
nucleotides on the complex immediately
suggested the idea that ex might be the
then very recently discovered guanine
nucleotide regulatory protein the
ability of an agonist to drive the
formation of this high affinity turn
complex is in fact a measure of its
efficacy or its ability to stimulate
adenylate cyclase and in fact the ratio
of affinities of the agonist for the low
to the high affinity form is a measure
of its efficacy and in fact those
affinities could be easily deduced and
calculated from these competition curves
so what we had here then was perhaps the
first direct demonstration of the mutual
allosteric regulation of a receptor by
its ligand and its effector in this case
the g-protein which led to their
reciprocal ability to enhance their
affinity for binding to the receptor but
of course one of the most important
consequences of developing these ligand
binding approaches was that we were now
able to tag the receptors to begin to
try to isolate them this was a truly
daunting task the receptors were little
more than trace contaminants of plasma
membranes and would require more than a
hundred thousand purification and then
only after we could find a way to
solubilize them from the plasma
membranes our ultimate success was based
on our ability to develop affinity
chromatography matrices in which we
covalently coupled various alpha or beta
adrenergic antagonists to sepharose
resins by bio specifically adsorbing and
alluding the receptors from these
columns in combining that with more
conventional chromatographic techniques
after a decade of difficult work by
numerous individuals in the lab such as
macaron susana Kotecki John Reagan
Frederick Lee Bloomberg Jeff Benedict we
were able to purify all four adrenergic
subtypes then known essentially to
homogeneity three of those are shown on
this SDS gel they were all as you can
see single polypeptides glycoproteins of
molecular weight approximately $65,000
each of these bound radio ligands with
precisely the specificity that would be
expected for the appropriate receptor
alpha or beta still some skepticism
persistent people wanted to know could
this isolated molecule also perform the
companion function of being able
to activate a specific process in a cell
that is to say to convey responsiveness
to adrenaline to address this problem a
talented postdoc in the laboratory Rex
areum reconstituted the receptors into
phospholipid vesicles he then took
erythrocytes from Xenopus laevis african
clawed toad these erythrocytes have a
dental h cyclase and receptors such as
prostaglandin receptors they lack beta
receptors and hence the adenylate
cyclase does not respond to adrenaline
ric fused his receptor containing
vesicles with the cells they acquired
catecholamine responsiveness
subsequently within a year we're able to
reconstitute the entire catecholamines
sensitive adenylate cyclase from 3 pure
proteins the beta receptor the guanine
nucleotide regulatory protein GS and the
subunit the catalytic subunit of
adenylate cyclase this work which was
done collaboratively with let's burn
Bama and the late even near proved once
and for all that our isolated molecules
were truly the beta adrenergic receptor
and capable of performing both functions
of the receptor now with validated
authentic receptor in hand we're able to
use chemical techniques antigen bromide
the gesture we obtained several
stretches of the amino acid sequence
which enabled us in collaboration with a
group at Merck to design our the
nucleotide probes which allowed us to
clone the gene and the cDNA to the
beta-2 adrenergic receptor the first
ligand binding GPCR to be cloned this
represented the first successful effort
in our laboratory of the young
cardiology fellow named Brian kobilka
what we found in our paper in 1986 with
that in the deduced sequence of the
receptor we could observe virtually all
the now canonical features of gpcrs the
7 transmembrane spans the
interconnecting loops sites 4n link like
oscillation at the amino terminus and
sites for regulatory phosphorylation on
cytoplasmic domains and in a remarkable
surprise for us at the time shown in
blue residues that were identical with
visual sensing protein the light sensing
protein rhodopsin 25 years on people
find it difficult to understand how this
could possibly come as a surprise but it
really did to all of us
the reason was that at the time there
were only two seven membrane spanning
proteins known read obscene the sequence
of which had been determined only a
couple of years before not by cloning
but by conventional protein sequencing
because it was so abundant and a
light-sensitive proton pump from
primitive archaea bacteria called
bacteria rhodopsin since both of these
seven membrane spanning proteins were
light sensing proteins it was assumed
that seven transmembrane spans must be
the signature feature of light-sensitive
proteins only with our cloning of the
beta-2 adrenergic receptor that the idea
began to emerge that no perhaps it was a
signature feature of g-protein coupled
receptors within the year we could
confirm that by cloning the alpha-2
adrenergic receptor based on john
Regan's purification of the protein in
the laboratory and then the alpha ones
and on to a total of eight adrenergic
receptors that we cloned as well as the
serotonin receptor three of those based
on the difficult work of protein
sequencing and so over the next few
years the idea emerged that there was a
large family of gpcrs all having seven
transmembrane spans over the next five
or six years the family grew rapidly as
many investigators were now able using
homology techniques based on the early
sequences that we and then others
obtained to gradually enlarge the family
but almost never again was necessary for
anybody to actually purify one of these
rare proteins to get the protein
sequence necessary to do the cloning and
so we always felt very good about the at
least in retrospect about the very
difficult decade we had spent purifying
these proteins the sequences of which
actually provided a rosetta stone if you
will which allowed us to clone recept
ISM and then allow others to clone the
receptors in which they were interested
we next turned our attention to using
several techniques to try to understand
how this highly conserved structure
seven transmembrane spans was
specialized to perform these two core
functions of ligand
and activation of g-proteins we use
site-directed mutagenesis and the
construction of the first chimeric
receptors in this case between alpha 2
and beta-2 adrenergic receptors again
Brian kobilka in the laboratory led the
way in this project alpha 2 and beta-2
adrenergic receptors are very similar in
sequence about 50% identical but they
perform virtually opposite functions
biochemically and physiologically with
the alpha twos inhibiting adenylate
cyclase through GI and the beta twos
stimulating adenylate cyclase through GS
we were able to demonstrate in these
chimeras that the simple insertion into
the alpha 2 receptor a little more than
the third cytoplasmic loop of the beta-2
adrenergic receptor converted its
function from GI inhibitory to GS
stimulatory over the next few years much
work from our laboratory and many others
led to the the current ideas that the
membrane spans and extracellular loops
were responsible for ligand binding
whereas the region shown in blue on the
cytoplasmic surface represented the
region's specialized for g-protein
couple in the course of doing further
mutagenesis in this area susana
kartikeya in the laboratory made a
surprising and serendipitous discovery
which was that mutations in the distal
part of the third intracellular loop
which would be expected to lead to loss
of function actually in some cases led
to the formation of constitutively
active mutant receptors that is to say
receptors which were active even in the
absence of a ligand at the time we
conceptualize this as being due to the
fact that these mutations must abrogate
certain intramolecular interactions
within the receptor that confine it will
constrain it to its inactive or our form
as shown here thus mimicking the
conformational changes that agonists
would produce when they lead to the R
star or active form of the receptor
which couples to G in just a few minutes
my colleague Brian kobilka will show you
how recent crystal structures have
helped shed light on what the nature of
those at that time on
known constraining forces and switches
were within the receptor interestingly
we now know that a growing list of
interesting diseases are caused by such
occuring spontaneous and inherited
constitutively active mutations and
receptors now contemporaneous would this
work in the lab on the structure of
their sector I have been very interested
for years in trying to understand the
virtually universal phenomenon of
receptor desensitization which is
illustrated here for the beta adrenergic
receptor in an isolated cell system so
one one stimulates the receptors with an
agonist like adrenaline or isoproterenol
cyclic a MP rises rapidly but then even
in the continuing presence of agonist it
rapidly falls almost to background
levels here's another example for the
angiotensin receptor with a different
second messenger a universal phenomenon
I've been fascinated by this phenomenon
going back to the beginning of my career
and I think the reason is because it's
such a classic example of what must be
the most pervasive phenomenon in
Physiology namely that when you perturb
virtually any living system it has
myriad mechanisms which tend to return
it back to its initial State
let me tell you how we came to discover
what is perhaps the major mechanism
responsible for this desensitization in
about 1980 a Jeff stayed L used some
probes recently developed photo affinity
probes to the beta receptor which we had
just developed to tag to label beta
adrenergic receptors in cells which had
been desensitized by exposure to an
agonist a beta agonist isoproterenol
and when he ran those photo phonetic
probe labeled desensitized receptors out
on SDS gel he found that their mobility
in the gels was retarded compared to non
desensitized receptors at the time it
had just been published that such
retardation in gels
was a fairly regular accompaniment of
phosphorylation of proteins especially
membrane proteins accordingly we labeled
ourselves with P 32 and Jeff was able to
show that the catecholamine induced
desensitization of the erythrocytes was
in fact associated with phosphorylation
of
sector over the next several years a
very talented graduate student in the
laboratory Jeffrey Benedict was able to
first identify the novel kinase involved
in this receptor phosphorylation we
called it initially bark for beta
adrenergic receptor kinase it's now
known as gr k2 or g-protein coupled
receptor kinase - Jeff was able to
purify it isolate it to clone its cDNA
and show that it was the founding member
of a new kind a subfamily now
contemporaneous with this work people
studying visual signal transduction had
found in a very corresponding way that
the function of rhodopsin when it was
bleached by light also seemed to be
reduced by its multi-site
phosphorylation and that enzyme had been
isolated was being called rhodopsin
kinase we obtained some enzyme purified
at calling it cDNA wolfing the lorenz
did this and found that it was a member
of the same family and so it became
clear then that there was a new
subfamily of kinase called g-protein
coupled receptor kinases today we know
that there are seven members of the
family two gr Ches one and seven are
limited to expression only in the retina
two three five and six are universally
expressed thanks to the work of John
Tesla's lab we now have crystal
structures for most of these this is the
structure done 10 years ago
collaboratively with my laboratory
showing the structure of gr k2 in
complex with G beta gamma with which it
binds to translocate
to the membrane from the cytosol all the
kindnesses share a very conserved
tripartite domain organization with a
highly conserved central kinase
catalytic domain flanked by two
regulatory domains but it turned out
that phosphorylation of the receptors by
gr k's was not the whole story of
desensitization something was missing
what I mean is that when Jeff Benedict
was purifying this jerky 2 or barque
enzyme he found that the more he
purified it the more it lost its ability
to desensitize the receptors in an
isolated system suspecting that we might
be losing something we kept trying to
isolate another molecule we never see
seated but then Hermann Kuhn about that
time the late whore Monken published a
paper showing that Annabeth abundant
retinol protein which was then being
called 48k protein or s antigen somehow
work together with rod ops and kinase to
deactivate rhodopsin and so the protein
was renamed arrested because it Arrested
signaling this sounded much like what we
might be losing although of course this
protein was limited in its expression to
the retina so it couldn't be the exact
protein we wanted nonetheless I called
Kuhn obtained some of his protein and
ensured a lot of benefit was able to
demonstrate that at high concentrations
it restored to our enzyme preparations
the ability to desensitize the beta
adrenergic receptor then at about that
time
Shanna Hara at the NIH cloned the cDNA
for 48k protein or arrested suspecting
that what we might be losing might be
not just functionally analogous with
visual arrested but structurally
homologous with it we obtained his clone
and Martin Losey then a fellow in the
lab was able to use low stringency
screening to isolate a 70% sequence
identical protein which we named beta
arrested subsequently Hobart a trauma
dolly or two later cloned another such
molecule we called it beta resting to
now with authentic validated recombinant
materials in hand and in reconstituted
systems we could show that within this
upper panel with rod opsin kinase
phosphorylated rhodopsin arrest and was
very potent in desensitizing where's the
two barrestins will we conversely with
bark or gr k2 phosphorylated beta
receptor the two barrestins were very
potent in desensitizing and arresting
was very weak this showed that there was
conservation across the entire spectrum
all the way from R adoption to the beta
receptor in this desensitization
mechanism however as you can see there
was great specificity for the nature of
which arresting was involved today we
know there are four arrest ins in this
family there are crystal structures
available for all of them to eliminate
in their expression to the retina all of
them share this
fold there are two domains amino and
carboxyl terminal consisting almost
entirely of anti parallel beta sheets
connected by a flexible hinge region and
stabilized by a polar call so where this
brought us to by the mid-90s was two
paradigms shown on this simple cartoon
which are in turn based on the growing
awareness that three families of
proteins and only three share the
remarkable property of being able to
interact in an entirely stimulus
dependent way with virtually all GPCRs
and those protein families are of course
G proteins G R K s and beta arrestins
interaction of the agonist receptor with
the g-protein leads the canonical
signaling through second messengers
interaction with jiya kaise and
barrestins leads to desensitization by a
steric mechanism in which the breast ins
block signaling by getting in the way of
the g-protein but within the last ten
years there's been a dramatic change in
this paradigm as we have begun to
understand that the g RK barrestin
system is actually multifunctional even
as it desensitizes the receptors it
itself becomes a signaling system in
which the barrestins are able to act as
scaffolds or adapters to bring numerous
signaling proteins into contact with the
receptors and set up signaling pathways
some of them are shown here with their
cellular consequences perhaps the most
studied have been the earth map kinases
in addition the Breaston serve as
adapters which bind to multiple elements
of the clathrin-coated machinery thus
mediating in the cytosis so barrestins
we now understand mediate three types of
functions desensitization and the
cytosis and signaling now in the course
of studying this newly appreciated
signaling through barrestins we made an
interesting discovery five or six years
ago and that was if so-called biased
agonist now a biased agonist is a ligand
which stabilizes a particular active
conformation of receptor they're
stimulating some responses but not
others seven transmembrane receptor
ligands for example can be biased at a
particular g-protein a beta arrested
mutated receptors can also
we biased now in the classic model to
state model of receptors an agonist
combines with a an inactive receptor our
and drives it into the active our star
conformation all signaling is then a
consequence of the concentration of this
unitary active state but the existence
of biased agonists
which can stimulate signaling only
through G proteins or beta arrestins
demands that there be multiple active
states shown here simplistically as two
active states one of which can interact
with G proteins and one with Burress T's
by way of illustration let me show you
some simple data illustrating the
ability of three ligands for the
angiotensin receptor to promote
interaction of the receptor either with
G proteins shown in red as second
messenger generation or with beta
arrestins shown in black as you can see
if the ligand is angiotensin a classical
unbiased balanced ligand you get very
nice and very similar dose response
curves for both the G protein and
barrestin if you use a so-called ARB and
angiotensin receptor blocker
which are used in clinical medicine of
course they're antagonists and someone
gets absolutely a no stimulation of
either pathway however if one uses a
biased ligand this would be a barrestin
biased ligand travina Oh 2 7 which is an
octapeptide analog of angiotensin as
shown in red it also does not activate G
proteins that means it's an ARB it's a
blocker with respect to G proteins but
with respect to barrestins it has very
potent ability to activate now I
mentioned to you just a couple of
minutes ago that one of the major
consequences of barrestin recruitment is
to lead to signaling in a fashion which
is parallel to and in many cases
completely independent of G proteins so
we were interested in obtaining in
gaining a more global view of what
signaling due to barrestins moppet might
be like and so Kevin Zhao in the lab
used mass spectrometry and proteomics
techniques to map essentially all
phosphorylation reactions that occurred
in a Cell when
angiotensin receptor was activated by a
purely barrestin biased ligand such as I
showed you which can't activate
g-proteins and I don't have time to go
through it but I simply want to show you
that in this very diffuse map you can
see that there's a huge amount of
signaling that goes on all these
phosphorylation reactions many of which
are very similar to or identical to ones
which can be activated through G
proteins this tells us several things
one barrestin mediated signaling is very
diverse and may be every bit as diverse
as g-protein signaling and too many of
the same pathways are activated however
almost invariably when the same pathway
is activated there are distinct
physiological consequences to the
different subcellular distributions of
the activated enzymes so in the last two
or three minutes I just want to show you
why we believe this new understanding of
these signaling pathways may have
implications for the development of an
entirely new type of therapeutic again
using the angiotensin receptor as a
model when the receptor is activated by
its natural ligand angiotensin we get
activation of both G proteins and
barrestins but the g-protein activation
leads to vasoconstriction elevation of
blood pressure which especially in
patients with heart disease can be
problematic however barrestin mediated
signaling can be shown to have
potentially beneficial effects
cytoprotective and anti apap Adak for
example now a arby's angiotensin
receptor blockers as i explained one of
the most commonly used drugs in clinical
medicine they they are used because they
block the potentially deleterious
g-protein mediated effects of
angiotensin ii raise blood pressure but
of course they also block potentially
beneficial effects through barrestin so
we hypothesized that a barrestin biased
ligand which would like a arby's block
g-protein signaling but actually
preserve or even promote barrestin
signaling might have added therapeutic
benefit in fact it's been shown that
such a ligand this o - 7 compound slows
progression of heart failure in animal
models lowest blood pressure and
increases cardiac performance in ways
that are not true of conventional AR B's
and is also anti a
tolik and in fact such a compound is in
Phase two clinical trials for the
treatment of acute congestive heart
failure
now it's also easy to conceive that a
g-protein biased ligand might be what
was desired in some circumstances for
example consider opiates the most potent
pain relieving medications available to
us it is known that they're very
powerful anti no susceptible pain
reducing effects a due to activation of
the mule opioid receptor and of the GI
family of G proteins however there are
also very nasty side effects of opiates
as you know they lead to constipation
respiratory depression and tolerance
which is desensitization requiring more
and more drug it turns out that
virtually all of those side effects are
mediated through the rest and mediated
signaling and are completely lost in
barrestin to knockout animals so one
could conceive that a ligand for the MU
opioid receptor which activated only G
proteins and not the Reston's would have
preserved therapeutic effect and
markedly reduced side effects so these
are just two particular examples of how
it might be possible to leverage this
new understanding of these two parallel
forms of signaling through G proteins
and barrestins which was gained remember
initially through biochemical studies
how may be possible to leverage it the
therapeutic advantage well I'm out of
time
and of course I want to acknowledge all
the many more than 200 individuals many
of whom are here who worked with me over
the past 40 years just to put up a list
of their names I don't think would give
a flavor of things and so instead I want
to show you a photograph which is
representative of the group
this was taken ten years ago at a
celebration of my 60th birthday party at
Duke at which many members of my
laboratory from previous years more than
a hundred came back to celebrate with me
and I do want to call out for special
attention one fellow hidden away here in
the last row
he is your neck he's your next speaker
dr. Brian kobilka thank you very much
and our next speaker here today is of
course the second Nobel laureate in
chemistry for 2012 Brian kobilka he was
born 1955 in Little Falls Minnesota he
got his MD from Yale University and he
is now a professor at Stanford
University
testing in here me okay um I'd like to
thank the Royal Swedish Academy for this
for this great honor what I would like
to do in the next half hour is give you
a a brief tour through my labs efforts
at understanding this really interesting
signaling process as Bob mentioned the
the beta 2 receptor like many g-protein
coupled receptors is a very complicated
signaling protein signaling through more
than one g-protein and having both
signaling and regulatory interactions
through a restin moreover the the drugs
that we work with for g-protein coupled
receptors often have really complex
behaviors as well ranging from inverse
agonists which inhibit basal activity
all the way through full agonist what
I'm going to talk about today is really
just a little piece of this fairly
complex puzzle and that is our efforts
to understand the the canonical
signaling pathway of a g-protein coupled
receptor to its preferred g-protein so
the the next slide I'm going to show you
is something that I first saw when I
came into the field and it was pretty
much at this level of detail it's it's
known as the g-protein coupled asperity
protein coupled receptor g-protein cycle
where we start with a receptor that's
inactive and agonist binds to the
receptor promoting an interaction with a
hetero trimeric g-protein the this
interaction then facilitates exchange of
GTP for gdp the g-protein dissociates
into its component parts alpha and beta
gamma which are signaling proteins and
then the timing of this event is
dependent on the hydrolysis of gtp to
GDP in the cycle begins
during the the past decade we've made
some progress in understanding the
different components of this that is
what what the three-dimensional
structure of an inactive receptor is
we're learning something about the
process of activation by agonist and
most recently the structure of a
receptor activating its its g-protein
and I'd like to tell you just very
briefly about this this really
interesting story so the outline for my
talk is I'm first going to give you a
brief overview of the approaches the
non-crystallographic approaches that
we've used to understand structure and
that have informed us a lot about how to
in fact crystallize the receptor I'm
then gonna talk a little bit about
efforts to obtain crystals of of the
beta 2 and other gpcrs and then finally
mechanistic insights that we've obtained
from these structures so reviewing a
little bit about what Bob talked about
in in his lab the the first clues to
receptor structure came from the clones
of a number of the genes and this is the
the 1986 sequence that was made possible
by by protein sequence obtained by Jeff
Benedict and from this nucleotide
sequence we can deduce the amino acid
sequence and then we can see within the
amino acid sequence stretches of
hydrophobic amino acids which gave us
clues that this was a membrane protein
in a multi expanding membrane protein
that as Bob pointed out looks a lot like
rhodopsin and it also taught us
something about the post translational
modifications glycosylation population
and phosphorylation early experiments
both chimeric receptor studies in
site-directed mutagenesis we learned
that the ligand binding domain for for
the beta 2 receptor largely resided in
the transmembrane sequences but on the
extracellular it's half and domains
involved in g-protein couple specificity
were primarily found
the ends of the third intracellular loop
but these approaches also were used to
modify the receptor to facilitate its
purification so we found that many GPCRs
and particularly the beta 2 receptor
does not have a natural cleavable signal
sequence and by inserting a signal
sequence and subsequently an epitope for
an antibody we can both enhance the
expression and overall processing of the
protein and facilitate its purification
through the use of an antibody column
and at the end of the protein through a
nickel affinity column and using these
approaches we were able to use a
multi-step purification process
initially expressing receptors in insect
cells solubilizing and detergents using
a midi affinity column subsequently a
ligand affinity column much of the
protein that's made in insect cells is
not functional so this is a key step in
separating functional receptor from
non-functional receptor and then finally
a cleanup step a nickel column and we
end up with pure protein that's almost a
hundred percent functional and this can
be used for a number of different types
of studies including biochemistry
spectroscopy and crystallography very
briefly what we learned from for
biochemical studies is shown here mainly
through the use of proteases we
identified fairly large stretches of the
protein the amino terminus the third
intracellular loop and most of the
c-terminus that was that were
susceptible to protease is suggesting
that they were unstructured or flexible
and this is something that's useful to
know when you're trying to crystallize a
protein but I think one of the the areas
that we learned most about the protein
was in the application of spectroscopy
particularly fluorescence spectroscopy
and more recently APRN NMR spectroscopy
to help us understand a dynamic property
of the protein and we learned as I'll
show in a couple examples that there are
ligand specific conformational States
there that the receptor is very dynamic
and flexible and character and that
these spectroscopy tools that we use you
ended up being very useful in monitoring
receptor activity particularly in
crystallography procedures our favorite
model system involves labeling 16 to 65
at the end of transmembrane six with any
other number of fluorophores and I'm
going to show you two early examples and
the types of experiments that we did and
the types of conclusions we reach so
this is a simplest experiment type of
experiment and early on these types of
experiments were first performed by or
gaither but this one was performed later
and in 2004 and we simply are labeling
the beta receptor a purified beta
receptor with a fluorescent probe in
this case rhodamine and that rhodamine
is in tucked in in the environment of
the receptor and when the environment
when when the structure of the receptor
changes the environment around the floor
floor changes and its intensity changes
so you can see here x 0 we add agonist
and we have this really nice change in
the intensity of the beta receptor as a
function of time but this wasn't a
simple exponential function it actually
was best described as a biphasic process
with a rapid phase and and this is
somewhat limited by the experiment the
mixing time so there was a rapid phase
in a slow phase and as Bob showed
functional assays early on where we
tried to model the receptor with a
simple to state system and inactivate an
active system state and and as Bob
pointed out functional studies were
beginning to suggest that this was too
simple and these experiments in fact
were more compatible with a sequential
model of conformational changes agonist
find some possible intermediate state
and then a final one
more active confirmations so this is a
this is one of the first about physical
evidence we had for multiple against
specific states similar experiments were
done using the same model system
cysteine 265 now labeled with
fluorescein and a different
spectroscopic technique and which is
fluorescent lifetime analysis and the
lifetime of a fluorophore as its
intensity is very sensitive to its
environment but if one has different
confirmations one can often see multiple
lifetimes at the same time so for
example this is a distribution of
lifetimes and receptor in the absence of
any drug two colors basal and you can
see it has a single peak that's fairly
broad and this would be compatible with
predominantly one conformation but a
very flexible conformation when we add
the neutral antagonists which binds to
and competes for other ligands but
doesn't change basal activity it doesn't
really change the fluorescent lifetime
but you can see it narrows the
distribution suggesting that it's the
receptor might be becoming less flexible
what's particularly interesting if we
now add an agonist isoproterenol we see
two distinct lifetimes again compatible
with what we saw on the previous slide
two agonist specific conformational
States and as I'll point out again it
suggests that an agonist alone can't
fully stabilize an active conformation
now if we take another kind of agonist a
partial agonist that has some different
functional properties and look at its
behavior we see like Alka Patera no it
has two peaks and the peak for which we
think is the active conformation is
different from the peak for
isoproterenol
suggesting that again yet another
conformational state that the active
state for for this partial agonist is
different from the active state for the
full leg massage pitarrio so we have
evidence for multiple agnus states and
ligand specific conformational
so these these experiments are part of a
large number of experiments that we've
we've conducted over the years more
recently including NMR and EPR
spectroscopy experiments which from
which we have the the following
conclusions that are that are both
interesting of themselves and also
relevant for for crystallography and
that the first is that the beta receptor
is flexible and dynamic and as an
example of that is this is a molecular
dynamic simulation provided by Ansgar
philipson and Ron drawer at the eShop
and this really gives you a sense of the
dynamic character of the protein this is
about a 30 microsecond simulation we
found that transmembrane six undergoes
the largest changes in response to
agonist agonist binding and activation
occurs through a series of
conformational intermediate-sized as
we've seen before Hagen is and partial
agonist stabilized distinct
conformational States what will come up
again is that agonist alone do not
stabilize a single active conformation
and this is important again for
crystallography and then finally
fluorescence spectroscopy particularly
has aided in identifying the optimal
conditions for crystallography so now
I'm going to move move forward and and
begin to discuss our efforts to
crystallize the beta receptor and I
would say we are serious efforts began
at the end of 1990s and early 2000s when
we were able to make sufficient
quantities of protein to start crystal
trials and our initial efforts involved
trying to crystallize the inactive
conformation bound to a inverse agonist
and this is one of the first really
exciting observations that we had these
are crystals that we generated in around
2004 with what we consider the wild-type
receptor it had these tags on but
otherwise it was pretty much on modified
and we were pretty excited we were
helped in this effort by get our
schertler who gave us time at the
microphones beamline in
es ORF because these crystals were so
small and weakly diffracting that we
otherwise wouldn't have been able to
tell whether they're a protein or not
but we we got this very very weak
diffraction pattern which was compatible
with protein but only 20 angstroms
nevertheless we were extremely excited
at this point because we had our first
protein crystals and we thought that
it's just a matter of weeks but it
wasn't so what was the problem well
let's take a hypothetical gpcr that has
uniform conformation a really nice
structure if you have purified protein
and they confer and the structure is
uniform it should be possible to get
high quality crystals because of all
these proteins will stack together and
they're in the same way what we had
though was a conformational
heterogeneous protein and our our our
spectroscopy studies showed us that at
least transmembrane six was quite
dynamic and and also heterogeneous so
now we have purified protein it looks
nice on a gel but these it molecules
don't really fit together very well and
the crystal quality is four so in
addition to the challenges of protein
dynamics we also had the challenge of
the the limited amount of polar surface
area most of the protein was embedded in
the membrane or for purified protein in
a detergent myself and so around 2004
I'm sorry 2005-2006 we started working
on efforts to overcome this limitation
and we took two approaches and I was
very fortunate to have two very talented
postdocs join the project at the time
Soren Rasmussen and Dan Rosenbaum and
they took two complementary approaches
and actually worked together on both of
them the idea was to stabilize the
dynamic component of the protein and
also provide additional polar surface
Soren chose to identify a conformational
selective antibodies antibodies that
recognize this region of the protein in
its folded form in
chose protein engineering and very very
quickly they both succeeded very close
to each other in time and and that these
two structures were published in 2007
the the beta to fab structure and the t4
lt4 lysozyme fusion structure yeah it
was really reassuring when they both
came out together because we use two
different approaches and the structures
were were very similar we we lack some
of the the definition in the
extracellular domains but the
intracellular components were virtually
identical in addition to these keys
these tricks that we use to help get the
structures another important component
was using lipid based media the original
crystals that I showed early on were
also obtained in in a mixture of
detergent and lipid the receptor fat
crystals were grown in by cells and
these crystals were grown in lipid a
cubic phase and this was done in
collaboration with vadim chairs often
and Ray Stevens more recently is in an
effort to get our receptor D protein
complex we found that you can even put
t4 lysozyme on the outside of the
receptor and not have and simply
truncate the the third loop and you can
get crystals in this way as well so this
is a summary of of the crystals
structures that inactive state crystal
structures that we've gotten recently
and the t4 lysozyme fusion has been the
most successful in our hands and and
probably in the field at least so far
you can see the muscarinic receptors -
too much grenades - opiates and and the
Proteus activated receptor all were
obtained using this method also in the
Stephens lab at Scripps a number of
other gpcrs have been solved using this
fusion protein strategy however I want
to point out that other methods have
worked and this includes the use of
thermal stabilizing mutations to tame
some of the dynamic character of the
protein has succeeded in
and obtaining crystal structures of the
beta-1 adrenergic receptor and adenosine
a 2a receptor this is his work from
restricted Christy did get our schertler
and their colleagues and I simply must
point out that rhodopsin was first and
read opsin so far it's the only
gpcr for which we've been able to obtain
crystals from native protein and in fact
the very first structural information we
have comes from Gephardt short lers 2d
crystals where he obtained these 2d
crystals in native rodiger segment
membranes and the crystals that were
obtained the 3d crystals from peski and
Okada also wrote an amicus trove of
lipids from from the retina and
detergents and and and more recently the
act of like structures from Bernstein
Hoffmann were also grown out of protein
purified from rot every segment so these
we believe the rhodopsin as a usually
stable character that allows this type
of crystallography to be performed so I
know when I get back to our efforts to
obtain an active structure and the first
question that we had is what do a
Guinness do can we actually trap this
state an agonist bound state on its way
to activating a g-protein and this this
we worked on for quite a while with
little success we were not able to
obtain any crystals of a receptor bound
only to even a very - be a guest and the
first structure that we ultimately were
able detain was one generated by Dan
Rosenbaum with help of ralph hall and
peter minor who developed a covalent
agonist for the beta 2 receptor and in
this crystal structure it was obtained
but it was in an inactive state so this
gets back to what we were learning from
EPR NMR and fluorescence spectroscopy
and that is agonists alone don't fully
stabilized in active state so this is a
cartoon of a GPCR I only have two
transmembrane to illustrate it but what
I show here is that the receptor is
flexible to begin with and when you bind
an agonist it appears that the
dynamic character actually increases
rather than stabilizing a uniform
conformation and so to stabilize you
uniform conformation you need a
stabilizing protein interaction if if
this isn't a g-protein then you need to
find some other surrogate and a couple
years ago I had the good fortune of
meeting Yan stare who's I think you're
in the audience who introduced me to
naina bodies and I can't go into these
in detail but they are remarkable so
they're they're the variable domain of
single chain camelid antibodies and by
camelids that include llamas and this is
pipette the first llama that helped us
to get a crystal structure and so in as
a stabilizing protein we were able to
get the first active state of the beta
receptor and and I'll just just quickly
say right now that this stay backed an
antibody stabilized state is extremely
similar to the g-protein state that I'm
going to talk about in a minute
something we haven't published yet is a
partial agonist bound state again
stabilized by an antibody that
selectively prefers receptor bound to a
partial agonist so now on to the
challenge of of the the true active
state the receptor g-protein complex and
this is a project that's been going on I
believe since around 2006 when Roger
sonar and I began working together on
trying to understand how we can
investigate the interactions between
these two proteins that hopefully try to
get a structure and this has been a
really fantastic collaboration that
continues today
this turned out to be a lot of work and
very challenging and and I really don't
have time to go into the this in detail
but I think it's useful to illustrate or
to at least discuss some of the some of
the important contributions to
ultimately getting a crystal structure
so the first involved being able to
identify a very high affinity agonist
and most of the agonists have even the
best Agnes have off rates measured in
seconds or minutes so and Rasmussen
screened compounds over 60 that were
provided by various pharmaceutical
companies and found one that had a
dissociation half-life of around 30
hours and this has been I think a really
important component of the success the
other important component is getting rid
of GDP the complex that we form that's
extremely stable is nucleotide free and
even a small amount of GDP that
dissociates or certainly any other gtp
destabilizes the complex and Roger and
his group came up with a clever idea of
adding a pie race to degrade GDP and it
really is fantastic at stabilizing the
complex other important contributions
are the development of new detergents in
collaboration with pills of che and Sam
Gelman we had access to these detergents
and they really helped us stabilize the
complex we had access to unconventional
lipids for a lipid a cubic phase from
Martin Caffrey these were critical we
also again had the help of yan stair
Nana bodies that helped to stabilize the
complex protein engineering t4 lysozyme
on the outside and finally a really
critical component to the project was
the use of negative saying
single-particle a.m. studies to help
guide our our crystallography efforts
and to to really cut to the chase we
finally succeeded in early 2011 and
these were the first crystals grown in
the specialized lipid at cubic phase
that were roughly these are relatively
large crystals in fact what we were
fortunate to have access to the Argonne
National Lab micro crystallography
system and this is these are this is the
crew after coming back from our last
synchrotron trip obtaining our final
date
and this is Annie Cruz Brian debris from
Rogers lab and Soren Rasmussen so I'm
going to in the last five minutes or so
summarize what we learned about the
structure so the this is the cartoon and
and now we have a three-dimensional
picture and there were some surprises so
first of all what I'd like to do in the
final few slides is take you from
agonist binding to conformational
changes on the inside of the cell to
conformational changes in the g-protein
and then this series of slides I'm going
to show the active structure is green
the inactive structure is gray
remarkably there are a few very very
subtle changes in the extracellular
surface with larger changes in the
cytoplasmic domain so binding here
amplifies conformational rearrangements
on the interest intracellular side the
largest change is seen at the end of
transfer membrane 6 as as evidence
predicted from fluorescence experiments
and you can see it's about 14 angstrom
outward movement this is from the inside
of the of the cell if we start at the
the binding pocket this is the inactive
state bound to the Universe againist
grass law and the active state bound to
this special high affinity againist and
when I'm toggling back and forth between
these two if you look at any one amino
acid it's it's it's really they're very
very subtle changes but which you can
see is the overall binding pocket
becomes a little smaller and I don't
really have time to show it but the
extracellular surface of the binding
pocket closes over and ligand
dissociation even even small ligands
such as isoproterenol and epinephrine
their desertion dissociation is
diradical drastically reduced because of
these changes and this can explain the
high affinity state that Bob mentioned
the g-protein dependent high affinity
State for Agnes has a lot to do with the
conformational changes that occur on the
outside of the receive the receptor that
are transmitted up from the g-protein so
that the the changes in the binding
pocket are really quite subtle amounting
to about 2 angstrom movement the largest
movement around Syrians 207 which have
been identified in mutagenesis studies
as being important for Agnes activation
so we wanted to try to see where these
changes propagated into larger changes
and right below the binding pocket there
are a series of there are packing
interactions with highly conserved amino
acids in in the family a gpcrs including
a prolene in 211 an isoleucine in tip
transfer every 3 so this is Pearl unison
transmembrane 5 highly conserved
phenylalanine to 82 in transmembrane 6
highly conserved and the spider gene in
transformer in 7 and I've gotten rid of
the other trans membranes just for
clarity these packing interactions are
really important for maintaining the
receptor in the inactive state and a
simple movement of 2 angstroms at the
top you know the binding pocket is
incompatible with this packing
interaction and a new arrangement is
stabilized as a result of agnes finding
and so you can see toggling back and
forth a small change in the binding
pocket of a fairly large change on the
intracellular side sufficient to accept
a g-protein or an antibody as i
mentioned though the coupling between
these is not rigid it's relatively weak
and and we've not been able to get a
structure of this really high affinity
agonist bound to the receptor alone we
need something here and in this case the
the stabilizing protein is not an
antibody but is the g-protein GS so this
in the last few slides I'm going to show
you the structural changes that occur in
the g-protein as it engages the receptor
so this is the blue in this case blue is
inactive model a model of inactive GS
there are two major domains the Alpha
grass-like domain
and the alpha helical domain and between
these two domains is the nucleotide
binding pocket and there's some really
interesting details about structural
changes that occur here that I don't
have time to talk about but you'll see a
major major structural changes that do
occur that are fairly easy to understand
so first of all I'll now toggle to the
active state and I'm gonna toggle back
and forth and you can see the largest
structural change is a very large
movement of the alpha helical domain and
opening up of the nucleotide binding
pocket which the nucleotide has been
released the other very large change is
the c-terminal alpha helix which
projects into the core of the receptor
and stabilize it in these active state
so this is the guanine nucleotide free
very high affinity interaction we were
somewhat concerned about this very
unexpected large movement of the alpha
helical domain and fortunately as I
mentioned and this just summarizes this
movement about a hundred and thirty
degree rotation of this alpha helical
domain and this was really quite
unexpected fortunately as I mentioned we
had been collaborating with jurgis kitty
otis at the university of maryland
michigan and his graduate student
obtained a series of really beautiful
single particle negative state images
which unfortunately we had tags that
allowed us to identify the components of
this density as being receptor a beta
subunit and alpha subunit and what he
was able to show is that in fact the
alpha helical domain is very flexible
and assumes many different confirmations
in a non crystallographic preparation so
in conclusion we've learned a lot in the
past couple of years about this really
important interaction the activation of
a receptor in a g-protein but there's a
lot we have we we still don't know one
is how these two how these two proteins
prefer each other why a receptor such as
the beta receptor for
yes / GI we also know a little about the
structural details of how a receptor is
phosphorylated by grk or interacts with
arrest and there there's a lot of work
to do in the future so I'm going to
conclude with showing you the this is a
picture taken last December at the GBC
our workshop in Maui this is many
members of the beta 2 GS team and and
many of whom are here who's Rogerson how
I want to point out talks on Bill Weiss
jurgis skinny otis is here on stair
of course I am I believe a Soren is here
as well and and and my lab manager food
Sun and in and I just want to put up at
the end there there there are many - way
too many people to really to have time
to think but I do I want to especially
thank my wife tongue son who's been my
colleague friend collaborator the great
mother and as you if you've read
anything about me you know the cheese
key to any success I've had I want to
thank Bob and and the colleagues in the
left quits lab I want to thank
particularly the people who really
helped me out when I started in the lab
as a very green scientists
Ruth Strasser susana Kotecki it really
helped me learn how to do some things
like binding Jeff Benedict and John
Reagan and Mark Corona really taught me
the ropes of protein chemistry finally
my lab students postdoctoral fellows
throughout throughout the my time at
Stanford and my two closest colleagues
bill Weiss at Stanford who is is
starting to teach me how to understand
the process of solving crystal
structures but still working on it
and Roger sooner sooner Jara a very good
friend and colleague who has been
working on g-protein signaling with me
for a number of years and that this is
the
- GST I want to thank my financial
support from the NIH generous gifts from
the mathers Foundation in Lynn Beck and
I just want to say a colleague of both
bobbin and my and I virtual woods was a
really fantastic mass spectrometer
spectroscopist passed away this year and
we'll miss him greatly
so I want to thank you for your
attention
let us take this opportunity not only to
thank this the two lecturers but also to
congratulate the two laureates